[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look at those new graphic yeah they look
great thanks Kurt
Thank You Kirk I thank you guys for
tuning in this is no I don't hear I hear
okay
I'm deaf you're deaf yeah must be too
many grenades too many grenades living
that Cod life I guess so
we're back in it it's the second week
for a cod beta apparently there are new
weapons and yeah hot gameplay you know
it Eric is eager to get in sorry oh
you're good all right so there's mortar
strike which wasn't there
I guess there's obviously in your level
cap probably 30 at least there's a new
weapon there's a couple new weapons
there's a new there's an m1a1 carbine
carbine at 26 so we can get that pretty
soon and I think this is a new sniper to
go 1903
there's no neon there's no new LMG and
there was note this was the last thing
that came right or SMGs and then there's
a new basic training called ordnance so
we have to unlock that 27 - so are you
close 25 I'm 25 I kept our progression
which is interesting
[Music]
they also up the team deathmatch to a
hundred points now instead of
seventy-five so we'll just do TDM real
quick
oh there's new gear the guys wearing
like an arctic suit yeah how did he get
that oh man man where do you change
oh here's the new map Rob I think you're
gonna have to manually open YouTube
check because it doesn't look like that
thing has YouTube chat for some reason
so in case you need it's at the bottom
you pop that chat out we got your back
Rob's gonna be checking out chat in
YouTube and twitch as well as periscope
maybe
oh this is an event in work I see the
YouTube chat now options doing welcome
carbine well I turned down the game
dude we're getting bombed this is a new
map Rob I like the urban sorry Oh was
pretty close I'd have no idea where to
go I've never played this map about this
I'm m1 garand awright now which I don't
know if that's the best gun for this map
this looks like I'm map that you could
snipe on maybe yeah good start
that's that Cod life yeah all those guys
you know all the muting like functions
in game I love this one it just
eliminates everyone in me yeah and then
it saves it to her throughout that's me
you can toggle it back on if you want
yeah well you don't have to obviously
dude nah dude hello pal leper good to
see ya because any questions for Tay or
myself for you just want to say hi in
the chat well do bleh go for it oh come
on bro I was a Stabbin so what's been
your go-to weapon so far
now that I have rapid ooo I got shotgun
now that I have the rapid fire on m1
garand I'm digging it that's the last
attachment isn't it no it's like level
10 there's like some stuff past it
there's like extended mags too if you
want that
the huafei is okay I feel like it's like
too fast for me like I'd rather Oh God
behind me I'd rather have the PPE SH or
whatever the second one was yeah I like
that one
yeah also love the STG a lot I've been
rocking infantry quite a bit just
because I like being a stabbed bayonetta
bin at Stefan know what I like bayonet
stabbing people the rapid fire for the
grant seems crazy
no this is the m1 garand I don't have
the carbine yet oh so that's just that's
a smart thing to do if you guys didn't
know if you see someone that has a
bayonet I don't know if you're ever
gonna see and react fast enough but you
should back off cuz it's a one-hit kill
with a bayonet so usually if it's like
an SMG or something and they try to
trade with you and they don't move
you're probably gonna kill them with
uh-oh so yeah that's where I was
confused cuz the Grand Hall has the mag
on the bottom and you're pulling the mag
from the bottom why maybe I have oh I
have extended mags on right now sorry
I'm mags cyborg man was Scott and I were
on the same page notice didn't have that
garand thing it's four more bullets than
your normal Grande magazine so I don't
know if it's actually worth it but you
might be cool I saw some questions here
in the open beta no this is closed beta
only if you have pre-ordered the game
you can play on ps4 but now Xbox one
right I don't know if it's out on Xbox
one today it would be came out early cuz
they're supposed to come out tomorrow
for some reason it came out a day early
again so not sure damn not sure if it's
on Xbox one yet but it will be on Xbox
one for sure tomorrow if it's not
already so it'll be their chance to play
this guy a piece of crap hey I got a
weird one to say says he hates to do
this but I need you to help us Brad the
capture gear tell him to figure it out
tell him that Nick
Nick's desk probably has one BBA Nick's
desk prize on my doors doesn't have time
flowing and one has a clip yeah so so
it's it's a you know I guess I have
extended mags it's extended mags with I
have rapid fire and I have one more perk
to that I can't remember it might be FM
j FM j ufmj to get do more damage to
like walls guy can't get a kill she
could save my life though right now but
we're leveling up what the hell right
there can be reloading right now Rob
that was definitely the number one tip
last time we screams OH
that instinct to reload you gotta fight
it ah we were in a such a great spot
though Rob I was gonna just keep picking
them off I mean they probably would have
eventually figured it out but they were
just funneling down that that alley whoo
he was not having it Rob had shot me or
he sniped me oh god there's like you
guys here are you gone
where's the other guy I know that you
know that I know that you know that I'm
here you granted me Teeling what a waste
of a recon flight have you used the new
fighter pilots yet it's pretty cool I
haven't I've seen it looks oh god I'm
dead
Oh big world war two plane fanatic Stuka
for the Germans suka which is the
infamous has the mounted landing gear
but that the Germans put Heller's on the
landing gear so when would get in a dive
they would intentionally create that
jerem Oh scream I believe I'm spring
that up but that's all that's Stukas you
hear in movies they would do that to
terrorize ground troops and then the
other one Nick locked his desk is sick
desk what if he took the one in here I
guess he could really should just be
recording this stuff
please Eric
mail a shot we just got triple that's my
play you're just warming up I'm we just
give him this yeah I mean first game not
not terrible not great we had our little
run if I had the STG if I be easier
oh thanks for the correction dukkha all
right it's 200 now I thought it was 75
appreciate it
cyka cyka today they corrected you yeah
I I didn't know that despite me taking
two years of German in high school
that's as good a plane is very cool and
then Americans have a 47 Thunderbolt
which try be f1 well you know the f1 has
been out we're looking at new games how
you like this map so far it's if you
guys are you guys are talking about it
on the LOB yesterday it's another three
lane based map so I'm pretty sure
Callie's not gonna be a huge fan of it I
like it I mean there's longer sightlines
come on
yeah that's why you can't that's why it
can't be spraying against the guy with
the bayonet oh I'm glad you're playing
who's glad I am oh okay hello and that
rabbit fire is real nice yeah it's like
I don't know that's what when I was
playing black ops like the the foul with
the rapid fire was like disgusting but
you hadn't like way more bullets with us
but it it makes me feel a lot more
comfortable up close and personal
because some of these SMG users I can
kind of compete with them because I have
crap didn't know where it was I just
feel like you can shoot faster and since
it's like less bullets to kill with the
m1 garand you can kind of like deal with
them if you have decent jumping tactics
he's got the jumps I really hope it I
couldn't tell their but I really hope
they fix that like scotum got him let's
see ya play the game here no I don't
think so no I didn't really get we're
streaming on periscope - Bob yes
the sniper Pam that's nice oh he's gonna
get fit Yahtzee nice that's nothing you
want it that's a common wolf yeah but
yeah that was pretty that was pretty
good play the game some play the games
are pretty like all right you know all
right we got 2016 18 Rob I think we're
getting a level up here so modest yeah
that's me though Oh what clapping hey
hey I wanted to do hey what's hey I
don't know I think it's like wow we're
leveling slow then oh man cyborg man on
a rant with with world war ii airplanes
I love it
bf109 is probably well not favorite
planes I like that no new face ones the
plane that saved the war point-to-point
the hawk what's up guys if you're just
joining us we are streaming some Call of
Duty thank you Eric for here well if you
figured or have not figured out you can
come just come grab this capture we have
here let's uh I'm gonna go infantry
again but I'm gonna go STG mix it up a
little bit give them that some AR we'll
try to get that carbine at 26 yeah
that's that's a yeah that's a reasonable
goal mm-hmm we'll get that we'll get the
mortar strike two I think a sure 97 5e8
for quick scoping I can't quickscope to
save my life I mean we'll try this the
sniper later I think it's gonna go
terribly but if we can get it thanks
cash army oh my gosh I should quit
that robbed that was embarrassing I
missed it okay you can kill me twice at
least thank God but you're back in it I
had the drop on a guy and I like just I
just choked it you'll choke I got you
again though clutch boy you ate that oh
it's blood boy
dang it Oh watch boy again far garner
asks a pretty good question in my
opinion for those who pre-ordered a
physical copy when will they get their
code to play
I don't know interesting I don't know if
that like did he not like an email for
it or something yeah maybe you should
get it depends where are you pre-order
dated I would expect yeah that's a weird
one like I wonder if I wonder if like a
retail store they're trying to camp Rob
to get fighter pilot they're not even
gonna lie that I was trying to camp
there
Wow he's sweet chimed into should come
in an email I wonder if that Comcast
thing works again should yeah those you
don't know apparently if you have
Comcast subscription you can yeah just
just call him customer service call him
up I did we got some guys in a clan or
at least some clan tag oh hello that's
what you get for not checking your ride
Eric what a new double cyborg man wants
to see some dual wielding pistols oh I
have that oh god I think you and I were
talking about that the other day like I
have not mastered the instant oh I have
not mastered the instinct to throw back
or nades I tried to hit our one there
while trying to run away that doesn't
work but it's actually pretty generous
though yeah like throwing it back you
can actually you can hold on to it
doesn't like at least the one time I did
it it didn't like blow me up right away
which is like weird darn it Tanner says
unlock the sniper bullet from
double-barrel shotgun a sniper bullet
how do I do that is that is that I do
that is that associated with the
mountain division is that like a perk
for him oh dude that's bad in so many
ways
cash army you can get now to level 30 is
that true
I just said that I think at least 30
oh sorry if those well did you could
feel like it's the determinant
determining factor would be that met the
new perk right
like I feel like wonder they've been
adding like new perks and those have
been like the level gap but we'll see
spray-and-pray and Rob it's not working
out I think you only get one Molotov -
now from the from the that kill straight
core Street just was only one they
nerfed it because - is by secure okay
yeah I feel like I was seeing a lot of
that especially during like hardpoint or
domination mm-hm
just letting those things fly yeah you
just like spam it yeah they only get 25
points though first you smart did it
before I could it's an unlockable
attachment on this on this on the
shotgun on the shotgun I guess
I stopped shooting because I thought
kill them poop
that's his poop alright so they want a
kimbos and I guess we're trying to
unlock shot dude I'm so bad with
shotguns though
oh what a throw goob from the twitch
chat says did XP levels roll over from
the last day they totally the audio in
this game oh hello well triple sublime I
love hearing these oh he's done it again
damn will play jiggly jiggy thought he
kind of strafe he freaking went up to
the top another good question
Metron says is a too late oh no I think
he could pre-order canceled I mean I
didn't tell you to do that but that
works I heard that that strategy works
you were trying to do that give it a
shot that kind of look like a person I
hope it wasn't shoot though oh not this
time
did the old fade away how do you not get
stunned Rob
I like the concussion grenades a lot
find them the most useful I find you the
most useful Rob oh good amazon has free
codes sick there it is
I don't even know what that means this
is just a page so yeah if we good
they're coming sometimes I get to uh oh
wow now the restream is working that's
good an important there for a second but
Rob's got it undercover
you're the master at it though
this is a big fake care package fake
deal their package what's the what god
this is the new killstreak just do it I
don't uh wait wait but there's three
theres r only 2 kills little man you
gotta be precious dude that's good
that's good yeah yeah that's good oh
there's no one there damn it
well good be good then I stole it at
least I guess I don't know
oh that's us oh hello sorry oh this is a
stupid the other one was better the
other triple was better where I got the
staff at the end I was boring come on
see that's one of those bad play of the
game yeah all right so I got a do they
want a Kimbo right
yeah well take a look at em bow let's
see I want to see that new perk oh he's
got a new hat
how do I that beret then you perk
ordnance I got to be level 27 28 to
unlock it okay so it's probably is level
30 yeah that's why I'm kind of go so
that's how do you change your
cool-looking gear let's see personalize
oh there you go so there's a couple new
outfits you can go us winter why would
you do that though Canadian sniper man a
US winter for that West tanker that's
pretty cool cool I love those goggles
I'll have two melons let me
airborne British commando 9 what are we
missing
did airborne armored was different
Oh expeditionary David that one looks
cooler fresh French medic looks better
than Soviet sapper shoot wishes duct
tape a tree doesn't look like you can
level your division pass for still
though so no classified weapons are what
right
oh sure what was that what that what's
that gun
that's the LMG alright that's the brand
ok the icon of it this looks really
different thank you so much how do you
remember to do all these things Matt
cyborg man had a good question do you
think that they'll roll out more
countries like Russian or ah but French
for office leads we're just all fine
yeah that's hard to say it's uh you
wanna do a hard point let's see a hard
point instead yeah that's hard to say I
don't know I mean maybe mapped themes
you know the history better than I do
oh yeah the war we have that we mean the
campaign is very much the Western Front
so it's like d-day invasion to whatever
point may be the end of the war but it's
only focused on the American infantry or
a American infantry squad so
yeah I mean maybe they'll tackle a
different run with DLC or
I wouldn't expect a single player DLC I
think so that's also
operates anyway hello apparently it's up
on Xbox nice go hit it up on Xbox if you
guys were waiting for that shadow fox
asked what do you think of this game so
far I enjoy it I mean I know that some
people aren't like necessarily fans of
like the smaller maps and whatnot but no
all right I like it it's cut it's caught
for me right right it's more of that uh
boots on the girl boots on the ground
experience you know we're not doing like
crazy wall running anymore we're just
kind of it's fine Lang like old-school
Cod yeah I like it yeah I wasn't too big
on all the wall running if I was going
to do that all the wall running just let
me play titanfall you know like why well
in the last clock didn't really kind of
own the wall running and mobility that
much like like there were wall running
areas but they were limited like the map
design wasn't so much cater to it but
yeah I'm kind of with you in that and
that's like you know there's always
there's only so many Federation's of a
game that you can like ramp up like it's
nice and refreshing I think so we dial
it back down boots on the ground is a
fine line said that is they're like oh
that's what they're saying
okay that's why I see so often normally
I thought that was just like catchy line
oh that's their strategy
not seen much dolphin diving me know in
general yeah it's actually a pretty good
shot because you can like dolphin dive
get back up like if you're crossing a
spot where you might get shot at it's
pretty good too like dolphin dive it I
like I just want to play the objective
I've played a lot of team deathmatch you
probably mixed it up more though huh
yeah I mean I'm generally a big team
deathmatch fan I hear I like having I
don't know a different goal in mind then
just kills as I go back and forth I just
feel like I would level up faster in a
TDM personally but it's not as good as
Julius B asks the beta is already love
love yes loved its loved that what he
means oh it's love baby smoked
five and eight pretty solid where's the
new heart point in the middle oh god
it's a death spot right there not even
get going do it I shot a fox follows up
with he hasn't enjoyed the pod since
party warfare do you think I think so I
think it's very similar experience these
maps are a little bit smaller I mean
even that bit that new map was it called
started with an a that one even felt not
that big to be honest
oh-ho-ho-ho did he roll up on him it was
yeah I was like four guys look at that
guy oh look there's another guy jump
right into it
brilliant to me Shannon Fox I would say
like the last handful of cod games I'm
just excited to play the campaign I
think this might be a similar case for
me here I think most a player is fun I
definitely like the change of pace I
like the war mode maybe we'll get into
that later
but yeah that's my take I don't know it
is refreshing now to like not have
jetpacks and gravity guns and all your
crazy hacking normally this tells you
what kiss when it told you what level
it's weird
26 we're real close to that so that's
good I want to see that and then what
was he saying about the shotgun oh you
got a double-barrel shotgun you got
three points there's a sniper round
these are all one token each right yeah
I mean we could try I'm really bad with
your the shotgun guy not me
doesn't take that much killing sure does
all right fine take a look at it should
we well should we go though quiet steps
I got this island steps on my house that
oh oh just on that loadout I have the
science I mocked it cuz it's level four
but were you gonna ask her how are you
liking the Colt pistol I've been using
that I haven't used it that much the
other one was fine I liked the other one
the P was it like forgetting the numbers
after it it's a Luger I think right a
little guy
all right let's I'm gonna try it I'm not
looking forward to it it's not even ice
I'm not even expeditionary so they were
saying that they're gonna nerf
expeditionary the incendiary rounds and
that it might not and you might not
start with them yeah yeah you have to
equip it yourself they're saying it was
doing too much
damage which it kind of was I could I
could see that Oh God do you even go 80s
yeah you're supposed to right because
then there's less spread oh that's a
good question yeah I think I would
imagine damn it
nope not from no mind me way too far I
got the hardcore Oh God alright I don't
know why I just stared at him just along
you're fine
no no it's a different life you live a
different life of a shotgun
I feel the cringe that the Internet felt
when I missed those shots I didn't feel
that's a normal day for me there it is
got him it's like an elephant but DJ fat
I won't fit a lot part of his name but
he says is the beta live well yeah we're
looking at it baby well we wouldn't be
playing it otherwise I first I thought
some guy was just playing like clods
yeah but he wasn't
we're actually is there like a quick
reload on this thing we're pretending
this is going to do from the guy here
outside Oh a new heart point new heart
point oh I really don't like this map
I'm not a huge fan in Gibraltar to be
honest but that's just me really would
you agree like I feel like it's just I
it's all too familiar of like where I'm
dying and like what I'm seeing it's why
does it take two shots Rob I don't know
I don't know I don't like the shotgun I
feel like this is that this is a point I
want that riflemen perk we're like
please barrel why where you want to have
that second primary so that you can like
switch to a SMG or something
Oh guidance do anything myself in there
DJ fat you're totally right that's a
good point I guess that's why they're
asking I keep forgetting what's up oh
yeah he probably good point he's like
yeah you're getting spotted like I
wasn't sure if you guys that's fair
that's fair I actually yeah what a piece
of but yeah it's it's the second round
of beta weekend it is live I think one
early now huh like they say like yeah
the 10/10 tomorrow again and it wasn't
and it wasn't it's no god last week but
apparently Xbox given Xbox and you
proved that time it kill them in one
shot and you can play yourself so this
is only for people who have pre-ordered
the game or if you have a Comcast
account apparently all them up getting
free code I have no idea what the heck
that's about I also heard if you get if
you get a razzmatazz at Jamba Juice oh
yeah
free xbox 80 damage Rob what's up is
there a beta glitch for Xbox like the
ps4 one I'm not quite sure that's where
like they do that weird download I think
oh he had a mind behind him man wait
that killer was that I didn't kill him
was that was that a bouncing betty that
kill you uh it was that little mind that
spins up so it could be the value study
that's in its in a new one it's the new
one they added like like in the later
part of the weekend right they like when
they made that update bouncing Betties
in world at war were were frustrating
but awesome I would use them all the
time yeah dude you can go that how come
that kill them in one shot was a
headshot upper mass gotta go upper mass
yeah I don't you know dude the shock is
like the shotguns here I like the
Winchester's yeah that's the one I like
I the double barrel is oh nice to have
two shots is just terrifying in a way
it's not bad though
like the reload is way too slow yeah
like am I supposed to do it kind of
makes sense as a secondary if you have
that like riflemen perk I'm just like
don't let shotgun just to have like a
quick answer in a close quarter setting
but yeah man I that works like when
you're like super close yeah Oh God
like see like I just cancelled the
reload animation accident I'm sure
there's a shotgun defender here right
there's got to be like someone here in
the chats got it like this thing I don't
really see people use this I see people
use that auto shotgun that third one cuz
it's got like five bullets in it I think
there was sniper
I got I got a aim higher that's what it
is
tank shadowbox we appreciate it he also
said game's pretty laughs thanks for
letting us know I was gonna ask you guys
how the mic and audio levels were we had
a little bit of a hiccup this morning
trying to get this thing going maybe
that's better not doing terrible
considering I don't use shotguns but I'm
not doing great should have my shotgun
out
yeah let's go that's real buy it now
yeah it's a little bit little bit need a
little bit that's good we're good we're
good
I figure this later things good I think
I need to step up my game
stop being now stop complaining you have
a good one too shadow Fox extra Turnitin
Oh what you put is like bouncing betty
right next to him I died the moment oh
oh oh yeah that's that's your living
that's it that's my shot good life I saw
the other guy you were really trying to
line it up there I don't like I know I
know I just feel like if I don't line it
up it doesn't kill and then like I get
salty about it quick reload perk would
probably is there quickly reload perk so
yes but it's not an attachment it's with
with rifleman no I swap your weapons
faster what's it with what I feel like
is like coupled with another perp
I need that hunter perk and you just be
able to roll and then like reload my
magazine oh God oh yeah I'll take that
that was not that was well it reloads
faster when you only have one at least
it's like accurate see like come on we
all saw me hit him upper master chat
saying they have school tomorrow they
got work tomorrow you know that work
life though live in that work life live
in that school life that's life also
pistol don't wait you know at school
today
yeah that's a good point three-day
weekends coming up though yeah I got a
four-day weekend though that's hot yeah
we need it I need a nice little R&R
going in under Barbara nice huddle you
could see me coming oh I still like the
Winchester better don't think I have to
paranoia real oh just like that
[Music]
what are you doing soldier oh I got
someone with what I don't have dad we
hit him twice with this strong shotgun
you know what we need a saw it off
that's odd fellows who's trying didn't
say my heart
I hope you and your family we're doing
okay yeah I heard it's kind of um
letting up a little bit yeah it seems
like see your left it was you don't want
to use this gun you don't have to use
this
fine no we told the chat we would do it
I don't know I won't get to the perk
yeah like like you know
now we're sisal ace yeah right when I
said that someone else in chat you see
that guy
yeah pink gun oh no you guys aren't
having fun watching me use the the shoot
gun
I'm always having fun she kept Anders
like yeah what because yeah the rifle
bullet is the last unlocks oh god really
not a penis
oh that happened I sacrifice my bar
all right fine go here we'll use the wah
fair the wah thing
imagine we do not have an extra beta
code unfortunately please well there's
three of them what do you got Comcast
you can get a good here
waffle oh good good job good job as a
paratrooper that just killed me you
killed on paratrooper get a hundred
twenty
iLike that type 100 and the I'm just
maybe I'm not good right oh good spot
good spot but I started using this
because it came out and we needed some
footage of it imagine I have no idea how
the Comcast thing works if you have if
you have an account you call the
customer service and tell them you want
Cod Bay dough productive that's like
weird but that is weird and also you
like I don't know imagine all the people
who are like desperately trying to like
fix their service and another guy yeah
people call in and ask not sure peyote
codes no no if I have that energetic
basic one on training on but I'm like
what does that do again a longer sprint
event which is like already a perk I
think I think for airborne right or is
it airborne has that other thing
like longer Sprint's or something that
is that way just that though ones like
longer sprint and ones like back it out
of sprint the sooner I just go off my go
to seven STG and Quran know about you
yeah I initially didn't like a brand but
then got real comfortable with it and
watching you use it earlier with that
perk her
well yeah II psh was my go-to
I really nice I really liked the
rifleman Burke like I love like having a
grand and then like a secondary shotgun
it just makes like all quarters really
taking off some dudes from afar and m1a1
is the grand right yeah no no that's the
carbine that we're trying to lock Oh
about the window I didn't do anything in
that game that shotgun the shotgun life
omajin saying that the m1a1 is amazing
alright let's try it out
should be able to get it hell I like the
grease gun more than the huafei I think
yeah what level do you get 26 which is
hopefully we're gonna get it right now
but I think now no I'm not gonna play I
think when we came in here and we're
about to stream I sat down thinking I
was in play and Eric says no I'm gonna
play and I'm happy he said that because
I thought I was come on alright we got
it
let's get out of this I have I have high
moments but mostly low moments and when
their lows are real low now I have low
moments - all right let's get that m1
carbine we're gonna have to walk the
[ __ ] out of it though anything different
pretty standard stuff here so this is
this is more of a higher range right no
so this is it's more range than the STG
at the same damage but way less fire
rate it's a lot slower it's half the
speed of the what's more accurate so I
guess it's a semi-automatic rifle that
fires quickly with low recoil can take
out enemies and three shots all right it
feels like another case where you want
that that fire rate perk do we have
we're gonna sprint again sooner and no
damage from falling is what energetic
does here we'll try that just do that no
damage from falling what's good
I've died - fall damage really yes I
have but like I think about maps like
Ardennes forests can't you know what I
mean where where can you die from from
after Russian Ardennes uh like the
brawler maybe sometimes when you jump
and like fall at certain spots like if
it's high enough you could kill yourself
like Ardennes Forest like let's say on
the far right lane where you're on top
if you happen to drop down from that
little little hill that you climb I do
where there's a there's like a capture
point there yeah yeah yeah
right there and I'm now also realizing
the bridge the bridge oh god is it
coming to be it was near Vito
Oh from behind that's the eyes oh it's
kind of like get in between it's almost
like a garand yeah yeah it's like a
garand almost which cool story
I always remember man taking Private
Ryan what's space Tom Sizemore Sizemore
has has a I was like Selleck oh I get
his name in that movie he's gonna grab a
ride useful Tom Sizemore let me get some
bangalore's
her then one a carbines good Rob but not
in Eric's hands oh it will be when you
get I'd rather have the Koran don't all
right I don't fall back I know that's
what I do I tried out weapon for like I
know yes and then I just like grind my
teeth until I switch loadouts the Koran
yes Oh God
Oh God that's all right thanks Adrian
inherit a heretic you said you were on
subbing twice now I don't know why
you're still here
cool did the unsub yet though he just
keeps saying he's done something
what's up dawn long that is a great name
Don Juan and it hits me I think I just
have to tap it faster and dislike
believe I gotta believe Rob that's how
you believe om VP parasite that could be
the pro player Sebastian says the m1a1
carbine is one of the most well known
weapons curious there's a really great
YouTube channel I've ever seen it I
think his the p-channel game is ahoy and
he just does like he takes a weapon and
he does he throws a lot of life
basically the history of like said
weapon but it'll like actually do
research and talk about it in the war
and stuff but like show game footage I'm
like as early it's like doom like all
the way up and I've never seen how
they're so cool
I'll show you what's up Adrian Hubbard
I'm having a grand old time right now
Rob this is worse than the shotgun I
don't know how but it is hey analyst
dream says it's cool I'll suck twice to
cancel out his unsub's sick [ __ ] wicked
sick that's what I'm talking about
that's what we need
I'm getting this trolley oh I got him
sure
oh I should have went infantry so I
could at least bayonet people yeah it's
probably pretty accurate and I'm just I
got to aim higher maybe you said that
spray life live in that spray life
what uh what right now I was so this is
a rifle yes they are
I'm gonna try it one more time yeah you
are yeah you got that guy
assault gun this is fashion w you know
that's a cool invention I thought that
would be great for like salads and pasta
and stuff thank you guys for tuning in
and hanging out with this I wouldn't be
shocked if that's the actual pro player
because he has a six thousand score oh
really
yeah we're gonna okay I got to go back
to TDM it's all I'm good at yeah when I
went to the cod preview event a couple
weeks ago I would i sat down and
realized I was at a table with one Pro
chaud players and then one of them was a
ali-a oh yeah a nice yeah and just like
within the first ten minutes was seeing
what having guys just doing no scopes
like with the sniper rifle just I don't
know it's amazing how quick those guys
can pull off shots Synar has got a good
one if you want to read that again got a
good one there he says hey guys enjoy
the lobby and love the banter do you
guys think the headquarters for World
War two there's a copy of the tower from
destiny which games can benefit from
this social space that is a good you
could speak to that a little bit better
right yeah like I you know there is that
trailer we haven't seen necessarily like
actual gameplay of headquarters for
those that you don't know like it's very
similar destiny where it's social space
so you can hang out with up to 48 people
and the camera will go into third person
you can kind of like I don't know I
would say it's it's great for this game
in
you can kind of relax if you had a rough
salty three matches and scratch there's
like a shooting range there's like I
think a range for you to like like hone
your skills with strafing runs with you
know the kill streaks the fight with
fighter planes kill streaks artillery
mess around with your buds do some sick
emotes but the coolest one would be
there's a 1v1 king of the hill arena
like a mosh pit and everyone can like
wait in line and watch even it looks
pretty neat we're like you there's a
scoreboard like outside of it and like
you can imagine like the idea being you
get on the scoreboard for how long you
can you can defend the pit like a king
of the hill type thing it looks really
neat and I don't know what the destiny
to social space is gonna be like if you
have a pretty good under the only thing
we've seen so far is the farm no idea if
there's anything other than that the
farm scene is fine but they what they've
shown is like pretty barren compared to
you know what the tower was so yeah hard
to say alright just got a shoot just
gotta really let them fly because it
takes more hello talk about a bad spot
to be in yelling it's interesting to
think about those social spaces Oh cuz
like I don't know if you can speak more
on this but for destiny okay he says to
molotovs so I don't think that change is
fun - sorry go ahead
for destiny it like was very much in
need
yeah because Wars and stuff yeah you
like you need but you need like a lobby
space to like meet up and like have
these activities are interval into your
play mm-hmm but here it's like no one
asked for a social space for hi yet
it's fitting in like the pacing of this
game and I find it I find it cool that
they like hold it in and like really
like thought about what else can we like
do opposed to like no you're not gonna
like they're not gonna put all of their
like UI and like upgrading options for
COD into an area right like that'd be
like super redundant like it they had a
thing about enter waivers okay there's
just like a bunch of stuff you can do
and you also don't have to come and I
think it works for streamers too like
it's like yeah it's like hey you guys
want to hang out here's the server on
then you guys want to challenge me until
I get king of the hill type thing
yeah show who's the best Wow mentality
because they used to have like good duel
1v1 outside of the town right yeah yeah
yeah it's like kind of like I challenge
you this gun could be good we need some
attachments maybe that's where we're
lacking other than my lack of skill to
possibly fill that kill and they got
grenaded nope I got bombed are there at
least we level up to three should be
able to get a sight on it although the
iron sights pretty much sign these thing
sign-offs our sign also says you can get
rewards from watching people open to
loot crate's oh yeah yeah so that's
something you could do
I know I almost want you to try this gun
later and just tell me what you think
about it I think it's just like you at
this rate I would just tell you I am I
do need to take off a plane no worries
well we'll see how long we last yeah but
people are still watching yeah thanks
guys you're doing all right here like
it's tough to to start off with a new
weapon you know I mean like like those
having those Superman or even three
right for a rifleman that was a funny
kill them all top I say that too Iran
Iran circles with that guy you just
didn't hear me because I have no no
footsteps / fun you think that's a
pretty big factor I'm always nothing I'm
I am loving it I the gun no no the perk
on it oh that yeah as the / Mountain
yeah I like it because I actually wear
ear buds when I play yeah we're like
headphones
oh yeah it's a pretty big difference
like you can
yep yeah this is good that's life
that is life this is true what's your
favorite it's such a favorite cold duty
oh man
probably em tub too maybe black ops 2 MW
4 hears they're behind us and in front
of us I don't like think it's my
favorite but like I played a lot of
world at war who who says what game is
this we are playing the ecology - World
War 2 closed beta if you have
pre-ordered the game for ps4 and now
Xbox you can dive in you should have got
a coder an email or however
we start so far back on this map reloads
pretty slow too to be honest
yeah we're just interesting that you say
that brand should have the most
frustrating reload like this gun let's
see it lets see it lets see it psh okay
okay that's one that's two that's me
you're gonna get the triple got it right
how the hell did he okay woah that was
messy I was real messy yeah maybe we
could try it with infantry maybe that's
that's what it is do better take yeah
I'm gonna try I'm gonna try harder this
next game for you Bob and for Rob Thanks
and I want to see it oh do you oh man
dude I'm so bad at this that's alright
that wasn't a match worth capping
anyways well 37 yeah I got quick-draw
helps have we seen a lot of gameplay of
zombies for this I think very little I
don't remember being that much is there
even a need to have three where's the
didn't you say I had unlocked the lens
it was probably for different weapon
I've had that happen so Jennifer the
shotgun yeah I've had yeah scope on a
shotgun right alright you want tools I
don't know if that would do infantry
though like just feel like you got one
perk oh yeah I haven't seen that yet you
want to see if there's a bug here the
bug so now that I've equipped a kimbos I
might still have a kimbos normally you
have to use duelist to equip there was
this thing that was like glitching out
for me where I could
I love it you actually aren't supposed
to reload the garand a mid clip IRL
mm-hm
I think Mike was telling me that he's
right but they had an iteration like
later on with the grand that like later
in the war like later parts that like
you could like remove the clip we
shouldn't be grant oh okay we got the
carbine I'm running infantry now so that
I can at least stab people I'll be good
that is pretty key alright Bob says to
do better Tanner says you guys decided
the zombies I heard David Tennant is in
it I don't know who that is my
confidante no I don't know who that is
either
that's why wouldn't I saw it I was like
he did the old uh curry I was trying to
stab him I was stabbed right over him Oh
Scottish actor sin doctor he looks
familiar
Doctor Who oh that's definitely familiar
yeah he was in a Harry Potter table fire
god I suck that's cool like how they got
that guy killed me after I shot three
times and I couldn't finish him off as
I'm a scrub yeah cool PPSh why don't you
try a new gun like me sir
an app 'some says the it's time they
implement like a map editor white and
caught yeah I'll be interesting what's
the difference between a magazine and
clip my dog last night I thought that
was the same thing I thought thank you
meet Joseph clarified oh wait is this
just set in Europe that's a good
question I think so I think the the
campaign focuses on the Western Front
feel like a lot of what we've been
seeing is just that as far as the maps
like that one get brought the brawlers
Gibraltar I feel like he's like I got
Italian no ass though I don't know yeah
you know better than I do
could be like French you ever feel like
sometimes when you're playing you just
feel like confident with like a specific
load out and then like I'm gonna try
something else just like why why even
shoot a gun when I could just stab
someone
allow me an all man I think of ll me and
I think about the 1942 I came that I
will hold very close to my heart I was
at a Klan once yeah yeah we saw it we
sucked
we never didn't win a single match it's
not about that about the camaraderie Rob
thank you I think a clip is a strip of
ammo you load into a magazine put the
string of bullets okay thank you
no that's me no no the wars I am copying
and shaving that so no Pacific says capo
Dei capi and yeah I don't think so that
would require like models right for
Japanese and even like American Pacific
Theater troops
I don't yeah I don't think that's gonna
happen but we can try have chat about
that earlier maybe some DLC Pacific
Theater Eastern dude that was good that
was pretty good I flashed myself though
I flashed myself every time I got
crippled because we all ran like a bunch
of turds thank you Jesus
who said the m1a1 was good I want a
refund
I don't know I don't know of that
you just confuse me more so I can clip
is like a short video and a magazine is
like a newspaper I know what that now I
don't get it now I don't even know it
was either those are I think you gonna
be back track
now this guy's using an STG change the
SMGs wear plenty of people are gonna
dodge this game they out pass every gun
especially maps and tunnels you concur
with that no I think the STG can compete
the m1 garand yeah Pete
but SMGs are definitely really good as
they are right now you with the grand
earlier we're definitely like doing a
lot better than amber now oh that's very
can't do it I can't do it anymore you
get I hate that gun right now I might
like it later but right now figure out
no dude right now that gun is look at
that I had time to turn on him and still
kill him oh my gosh
man copy a copy is making now he's is
that right he says oh oh oh they're
waiting I mean I could be doing damage
to your to your play right now just by
talking that way no that's not that's
that's definitely not what's throwing me
off it was a hundred percent that guy
not that I'm doing any better now great
and says perhaps maybe you're spreading
around too aggressively around quarter
corners so spreading from cover to cover
and I would call a truce I just don't
have patience that's how I play yeah oh
that's hot
that'll do it Oh what was that
what did you say oh he says capital
Cathy says click goes in a handgun in a
magazine goes in a are now I'm Morton
aim higher Eric geez we had the aerial
flight there if I didn't choke what
happened that she gets hired mid charge
signs of sick pay yeah good clean up
suck
oh dude we're so close to winning flash
losing I saw you I am excited ninety-six
ninety-seven Rob you got no you're good
you're gonna do it
yep yeah baby yeah baby
no I'm excited as well for Nazi Zombies
my only request for that game is
hone it back I'm a big fan of like the
more simple sickness like you neither
end it up for him
type 100 right there just yeah but wait
man they're really getting into this
whole clip magazine thing so the what I
just last said kappa - kappa - kappa t
kappa kappa d kappa kappa taggcat be
what he said about a clipping for a
handgun and a magazine for an AR oh my
god you're right you were really going
off peeler saying that's wrong what
cliff is just a small piece of metal to
hold bolts together think of them like
the m1 block chip the magazine is the
actual box oh now I get it
yeah yeah it's okay
I get it now okay expound oh you wanted
to again so I thought that like it was
just like okay so I'm you have your
magazine in the magazine that's the
magazine is the actual entire the entire
piece of trying to phrase it right
without saying clip it's it's basically
the entirety of world all your bullets
is the clip is the piece of metal that
is inside the magazine that holds all
the bullets gah ah I think good to
switch that one did ma get a score
screen yeah there's the new one I
haven't gotten in yet cuz I got a 28 you
did but we didn't get to really see you
in action
oh we're gonna get oh that's true I shot
I fired them yeah and they hit
absolutely nothing and they bricked the
game globally and Adly yeah the vessel
sure full mile jacket for my jacket sure
that Brenly yeah I could just google it
that's true you do have that you do have
the capability of doing that I always
forget when do we get it does it say why
doesn't it say it said it before the
thing was 28 though okay so even what I
just said was wrong
really I guess there's headed I thought
I did too there are uh there's just so
many different opinions in the chat and
I'm getting not sure why it's not on PC
I'm a married [ __ ] I was right okay
maybe they're trolling so says writing
explained dot org and ammunition ater
secretaries later dude an ammunition
clip is a device used to store
individual rounds of ammunition together
as a single unit that is then ready for
insertion into a magazine of a gun for
rifles with an internal magazine to clip
loads the bullets into the firearm
itself I was right it's like the piece
of it's what holds the bullets together
and then you put that in the magazine
nailed it Rob
haha I'm back baby policy not a hundred
percent sure about that but that little
run felt good so that's a good start
question is are they spawning on that
side still yeah their helper you are
probably right
I don't know anything I'm still probably
saying it wrong but you know what
that's life that is life you gotta break
some eggs once in a while to make some
eggs to make more eggs you got to own
that mistake got it you got to learn
some way although I guess a lot of my
kills have come off knives knife kills
though hi I agree cake thank you you are
pretty good with the bayonet like your
tiny good it's my actual shooting though
is not so great
it's like is it all God okay it's ten
kills to get a recon plane is it no it's
five five about five depending on what
else you do you think that's high
no necessarily alright I'm not back guys
I lied went from four and one two four
and five that still wasn't the kill
Molly
sian asked where did Mike go he's hasn't
been on the lobbying last two weeks
appreciate your concern he is taking a
little vacation he was in New York for a
week he will be back next week there's
new kimbos guys and we came with a win
man the mounted turrets in this game are
very awesome you and I have had some
good times mg nest yeah it's kind of
nice I feel like they I mean they're
really overpowered but it's like a good
incentive I mean you're sitting duck
regardless like you can can't be on it
for all like and try to throw it back
dude and he died
what the crap was that what was that
there's another guy of course oh that's
right isn't it the carbine was like a
big airborne weapon I believe first like
sighs probably wrong on that
hey guys gonna try to drop the history
knowledge on you but I'm not positive
that could be wrong did you go do you
want to know more would you like to know
more
new cloud says get this man some Doritos
and down do yep yep I need it
Dusty's gonna have like that double XP
uh Doritos stuff Oh God
what else what do they do that also for
level XP pop-tarts - pop-tarts mm-hmm
bird destiny at least not a fan of
pop-tarts hey Bronson that's pretty good
there's someone behind us I was feel
like I screw up pop-tarts and Rockstar
the perfect combination for your morning
get up get goin get that brain filled
with pop-tarts why would you artillery
where I'm at
Samantha asked the guns are balanced
any guns working done so smg's right I
think that's kind of like a sentence
with people of their worth using that
sounds really great
I got a flight though here where that oh
that's good oh yeah p-47
I wish it did more damage you see how
many times I had to hit him Oh God he
can do this I was right about the
carvanha they were smaller and lighter
and used by paratroopers you oh you were
ah no there's another guy what are you
gonna do there uh challenge the other
guy
Fight Like a Man instead of trying to
run away that's what I should have did
Rob what I get cool all right please
please Macari says there's always
another guy
there's always another guy at least in
team deathmatch actually in oh god
that's a bad guy that's the guy that
just killed me think what's the
one-to-one not anymore it's not
that's what this stupid carbon - yeah
cool
getting spawn camps it's like now we got
to try to hunt that guy down want
someone kill them were you kind of
steering that plane of me not really
like right no you're just aim your
gaming yeah I mean the turrets yeah oh
man I'm loving the p-47 chat oh yeah I
love World War II airplanes they're so
freakin cool
it's like you think about World War one
it was like no one really knew what
they're doing eight like towards the end
of war they were like figuring out like
oh we can like drop bombs I guess like
people there were a pilot's who had like
a shotgun with them that they would
shoot at other planes will fly like what
war - like innovation and like
air combat and like figuring out like
planes and speed there's so much to like
consider but uh p-47 would look at them
that zahle guy said which is interesting
are you ready for this I am yeah he was
there
No my shot too low I think I've been
spoiled by the perks of like my other
guns I've been
I was a pretty mediocre started off good
Eric I gotta run alright you do that
thing I'm gonna play one more it's okay
one or two more maps and then thanks for
joining me the hell yeah dude
always thank you guys so much for
putting up with me now you get Eric he's
gonna kill it
am i I'll try it trust me when I leave
this room you're gonna do better I know
y'all have a great rest of your week
I'll see you guys next time
later Rob's all right I'm gonna scooch
on over a little bit he's just running
in this F o 27 do we unlock anything oh
we got that new ward ordinance thing we
could try that let's see let's find out
oops we gotta keep that for the kimbos
huh it's cheaper scorestreaks
an ability to reroll your own care
packages actions
alright let's let's change our loadout I
don't know what we're gonna maybe we're
about to find out we've got the fight we
about to find out chat
all right it's just you and me chat I'm
gonna use some real guns now I think
perhaps whoops if I have them set up
still I don't know if I still I think I
killed my Granma steak all right we will
have to try I think I have my STG
loadout so we'll use the SDG let out I
guess maybe it was robbed I doubt it
though
oh no that's still missing perks
well I don't actually like any of these
I will try it I tried that peepee
airborne oh wait but I can't because we
need the Ordnance loadout all right we
got to go with this this is the only one
that has the ordnance loadout got the
type 100 I do some work with the type
and we're doing good start obviously got
to remember that I don't have the
bayonet anymore
we're pretty close to firing something
what are you guys doing those situations
you guys try to like get like better
cornering cuz I feel like sometimes I
don't do that okay I'll do the best job
of hitting the corners as well oh wow
so the recon is only 375 instead of 500
which is quite a lot less care package
looks like it's a hundred less and the
fighter pilots like 125 so that's pretty
single obviously forget what the perk
was called an old project Wow did he I
guess he must have a dope there forgot
what the perk was called though that
allowed you to kind of
have cheaper killstreaks I was like ooh
a nice night she jumped maybe would've
lived probably not though I loved the
quick Stoker's oh he's got a he's got
like my gun now I think great oh it's a
different guy I was like dude
smg's are pretty good in this game
though if you guys haven't noticed
either me getting killed by them or you
know don't know what that guys doing
dang it
the mini-map is some I use this that's
not true like if you can see when people
start shooting if they don't have the
silencer attachment and only airborne
has silencers so but you're shooting
your teammates
dan this gun is ope yeah it's all right
type 100 sorry I think the pph PPSh is
is stronger honest I need to try to get
upset I guess I killed oh no that was it
oh we got it okay we got the Recon
that's all I know
guess I'm assist points
it reloads really fast though is the
good thing about it I guess Wow
I'm sure if he was actually aiming him
well it didn't look like he was what
position are you asking about I think
it's just like tactically like moving
like I think I wrote like someone made
the comment that I sprint a lot and I'm
like a yokai in the house I think I just
got to choose better routes
I feel like Oh someone talking about
actual squads see I was the P P HS SH it
does more damage than the type 100 type
100 has more range but the PPS a has
more damage like significantly more
damage
and we're about to win I will try again
I'll put the thing I'll put the
ordinance basic training on more than
what happened to the other guy here to
go do some other work so apologies that
he had to dip out a little bit early but
we'll be playing a little bit more I
appreciate all you guys being here
we're live every day at 11 a.m. gamespot
live play new games betas DLCs well we
played a bunch of destiny next week so I
hope you guys are looking forward to
that doesn't he - of course and yeah
tomorrow we might play Ark survival
evolved maybe we'll play some more cod
we'll see all right so we need to fix
some of these we'll leave one there so
that we can
okay so hopefully with that we'll be
able to get some more killstreaks
Mostafa suppes I mean there's a lot of
people in the office doing things and
it's no big deal to solo stream for like
another 15 20 minutes just playing a
little bit more so that we can test out
that ordnance division or basic training
rather I also shout out to all the
military people in the actual stream
thank you for your time and service and
thanks for tuning in of course I haven't
gotten that new map in a while though
which is unfortunate I don't want to
play that new map some more oh I should
have made an m1 garand loadout huh oh we
might I got booted there so that's
actually not not the worst thing here
all right please give me the new map you
can replace um flower master that's true
the chair looks so lonely I could just
get rid of it no I can't actually kind
of I kind of got rid of it
maybe we just need to play something
else trihard point up it says it's the
new map but I don't think it'll give us
a new map huh thanks Mustafa yeah I mean
there's some stuff we still haven't
unlocked and there's still some of y'all
watching so might as well show it off X
and HSD I'm not a hundred percent sure
if you'll get a code right away but if
you preorder you should in theory get a
code to try the bait out so you can also
move this microwave watch Michael m1
garand here
and yeah I do
I do understand everyone's frustration
with the it's pretty annoying I mean
there are other viable weapons it seems
like these are so good I don't even know
how he killed me there he's like falling
away from the window
ah and no one watching down Main Street
huh
that's the only problem with the bayonet
is the animation is pretty long so
chances are if you've been had someone
like that you're probably gonna die that
guy's gonna lie headshots though so
kudos to him
good
how do you put on the hardpoint just
start shooting like gun more on people
instead
okay just must know all the spots he's
destroying us yeah that guy is going ham
look it took all four of us but we
finally killed them
d/f is way better i mean different kinds
of games i can see why you feel that way
though
[Music]
how do you know dude he sniped me
interesting
or it takes the trouble like in the
world at war I don't know yes I know
stick your car out of my way you car
just like here let's throw our lives
away try to get this hard point or on
the other side now
I just heard a silencer
that guy silencer don't cut that guy's a
man the King clan is real
we're just getting like six stacks oh
god that was awful we had three people
was my best round yet guys 12 and 28
this guy is really good aim though maybe
not there that's to play the game how is
that the play of the game oh I wonder if
it's because the rest of the people
weren't there so then it doesn't
register it or something yeah alright no
more no more hard point I think single
player will be pretty good though for
cod so I'm hoping that single player is
good
alright cool we got the new map we play
another bad game we'll probably just
call it cuz it's probably gonna not be
so fun to watch obviously started off
strong though
oopsie deathmatch time you show what
you're made up soldier
move out take position enemy they got
full squad don't know what I could run a
CT would be better probably I don't get
why we start so far back
[Music]
aha panic knave
I hate Activision they ruin everything
they get their hands on those from a day
job I don't know I think that destiny is
fine I'm not a huge fan of that whole
like pre order to get an exotic who
knows if that exactly good on it
I must play smarter as I run down the
middle the street should probably strain
instead of reload there
yeah blizzard still doing fine but
they're probably just like we're like
you don't touch anything
that's this early date yeah they get to
this side right lizard trolley
we climb that
I deserve that
I should just knife them I think they're
both looking now
back then
like mantling bug there
awkward hang it that guy got sick of it
he was like I'm just gonna chill back
here y'all spawn camping us guys there's
a guy in the back left building 100%
whoops was looking in chat wow one guy
actually escapes
they finally get smart and like stop
pushing out
weird holy a red marker all right cool
crazy that they can put that thing like
right next to them and not actually like
die from it
steal it boys
well I wasn't terrible wasn't great okay
that's pretty good though but like Nick
brought of a good point that like in
battlefields when you bein edit someone
you like them paint head is a ripoff
from the game Bayonetta sure all right
we try one more last one for sure 100%
somehow managed second place but don't
really deserve it hey whoo we're almost
28 though we might be able to get the
mortar strike
I'm not sure if the beta is actually
open
Guillermo Sandoval I don't if anyone can
confirm or deny that that'd be pretty
interesting we're gonna try the PPE
ppsh-41 we're gonna do some work
probably should just want to type 100
Wow I'm bad kind of just expected him to
die and he did not die Here I am hyping
this gun up to you and dang teammate
almost saved me
what's why you got just spam reload why
what like bad timing just like run into
a bomb or concussion name
he's gonna protect me that was in front
of the box
I see back off Reese Conlon school
Kristen is actually pretty solid like
start off with it
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god there was three of them that
could have been the dream
cool yeah they haven't announced Oh Oh
have they opened announced open beta I
don't think so guy or was it just that
guy
your head
by only a decent run
oh there's so far
try and get some killstreaks here
so a fun fact you can shoot it to make a
drop a little faster I guess I could
have got a double tap it was sexy
we got double chafing runs though it's
not great right now because we have no
vision
oh god sounds behind us so that's how
you would take default damages
and you guys give me eyes yet
dude why do my other pilot run just get
I do have another one okay
you guys are near the barn huh
[Music]
just trying to get a less where do you
think yet
I will go to straight down the middle
no care package quick don't kill anyone
team all right so what's the thing in
doubles have to recoil or we can order
it no we just got the mortars
that's the grease gun
boots-on-the-ground it what's it all
it's true man wasn't even that good of
run thought I had a good run there huh
all right we're gonna see if the next
one is a new map or not if it is oh we
got the motor strike I think all right
cool let's try to get that Oh No all
right maybe we don't go recon whoo this
is gonna be risky no recon that's fine
we'll try it with no recon
I am really struggling with this gun
I think I got to put the site on it I
can't it's hard for me to iron site yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna keep going I'm gonna
do mortars I'm gonna try to get mortars
here dude there's no one left in this
game
come on new map and mortars now we don't
want your altar
does that even matter I don't even know
if that what matters the way it does all
right we got the new map all right
do I Makara do you miss the mobility
from the previous cause or are you
getting comfy was just running I'm
getting comfy with just running ie
we talked about earlier I'd rather have
this experience than the wall running
but that's just me personally kind of
curious what the rest of chat thinks
oh my gosh shot try to back off can do
it
anybody
those sloppy though I could kill that
other guy and had like any little bit of
ammo left we couldn't go that guy
probably that guy's using the my
anything to some success it looks it is
out early today sooner than expected it
was supposed to come out tomorrow I am
just like last time they went a day
early not sure why they tell people and
then I'm sure they updated it in there a
tweet or something but
I just slash myself Yolo wonder if I
could have a bayonetted bayonetted in
Ashland oh that guy's still there
all right that was my bed a lot of
places to hide on this headglitching
spots that guy's just been crouched over
there that window we have done nothing
about him I take the grenade for that
guy get out the way
molotovs pre-emptive Molotov is like
you're not walking past this point the
other guys protecting him on the other
side damn we gotta go all the way around
yeah saw coming gone cold
sorry Big Foot stole that
oh I was just jumping knife
why don't you work
it's always that
[Music]
[Music]
ycs the m1 garand I'll use the m1 garand
type 100 spine I just got there well
yeah I mean right now there's a lot of
the same guns I mean there was a couple
guns that just came out there was a new
sniper there's a new new sniper new
assault rifle that I wasn't big on yeah
that's just kind of how it goes god
they're just coming in waves and I'm
just not getting enough to get more than
one guy and yes
it's behind you and you hear it clearly
for some reasons I feel when I get
something you did when something
actually happens I can hear it when
someone's behind whoa he blew himself up
I mean I can show that m1 grand God
would a not so great
actually I should just be using the new
gun to be honest but that gun is not the
business for me personally oh it's right
there we have a third oh we got it there
maybe with the reflex it'll be fine all
right wish me luck guys last game we're
gonna hope that I can use this gun so
I'm not really a big fan of it though
cool to see you know some of the chat
that have you know either join the
military or and we we here appreciate
guys this is the m1a1 carbine kind of
like a baby grand in a way just in terms
of like how it shoots takes three two to
three shots though not see that guy
here's what I did not think he had a
shotgun running around like that and
like dude
well there's definitely some really
going on though people have been
teleporting a lot more this beta than
the last one don't know why like even
though I'd died there like like that guy
look at that guy he's still struggling
that guy
save us just feels really stiff though
it's not as we would it is a
semi-automatic though so maybe it's to
be slightly expected
and they just had all the good spots I
the other side of the map pretty good
and once you have it held down it's
pretty tough on this side you kind of
walked in yeah those guys almost need to
flank a bit to try to take 100 we almost
have no choice but to like kind of like
[Music]
I was trying to aim low because I knew
he would prone
Wow look what was that you like all of a
sudden accelerating oh I just fell down
[Applause]
hey hammy saw me really trying to push
so that we could get out for the team I
can't believe that didn't kill
that's my last game goob hasn't been
going super swallow either it's not a
big fan of this guy suppose
know what to do man
now someone said that it was on Xbox
I haven't confirmed that myself but
y'all can definitely check to see if it
is on Xbox because it's supposed to be
on Xbox this time around - first one was
ps4 only this one is for both I don't
know if it's out today for both though
you're playing ps4 the stuff carried
over to you just got all the spots on
lock
and we're never gonna get that mortar
strike not unless it's my care package
it's on Xbox now okay cool thank you
lab labonte relavant
yeah you guys don't like that one not a
carving because I am not having
successful I have the whatever site this
is now sorry do you dr. Wolk you're
right I did suck that round I just I
can't I don't think I can use this gun
like every time I try like I just got a
really horrific score not saying I'm
getting like a crazy good scores either
hi this gun is definitely a struggle I
don't know why the time to kill feels
not so great
10 and 20 like watch I'm gonna play one
more game just because I want to show
that like it's that gun primarily that's
giving me the problem also for myself I
should have left two games ago when we
had that like one solid game but is that
one more mentality and since I'm by
myself no one can really stop me right
that's how I look at it but thank you
Abhijit gear it could be the rate of
fire it could be the damage maybe like
in that case I don't want rather just
have that one granite which is what I'm
gonna use now because someone else was
like oh all I see is these two guns
is anyone using anything else and use
that one Grandin
great start
yeah it could be one of those days
for one of those games it's not the gun
it to you yeah I'm just not good with
the m1a that's I will 100% up to that
I'm asking if anyone else has gone that
gun and doing well with it
that's weird
deserve all right maybe you're right
maybe it's just me I'm done
do it dunzo
maybe streaming is not easy got us all
the streamers I can lake I want to
charge them sometimes you just need to
go on a run like basketball you know
start getting a couple kills don't
competeing again you know
let's get you a spot to begin right now
because I'm trying to want to get my
care package time to punch it up with
some positivity thanks Tom Google's
Google I appreciate it
I so appreciate the people criticizing
me to you because you know sometimes
you're just not doing well and that
happens why did that sound like your
name yeah I'll fire I was on fire
not anymore try to end on a hopefully
positive note
why did that not kill like pretty sure I
tagged that one guy like new is coming
someone was bound to flank us never quit
never surrender yeah
their eyes full hearts can't lose
no way dude man I can't believe that
missed I'm so sad right now well it's
not looking good real pro strat right
there yep alright I tried I tried I was
awful it was me after all guys
yeah killer streak here yep but anyways
thank you guys all for watching that was
a cod beta the second wave I guess if
you were playing ps4 you should have
kept your levels and progressions
there's a new mortar strike there's a
new m1 a1 carbine there's a a new
ordinance basic training and there's a
new sniper - so go try that out if you
haven't I appreciate you guys tuning in
and watching bayonetta stab is pretty
good and also there's new outfits too
guys if you haven't seen them there's
also in the outfit so check those out
but until tomorrow see you guys at 11:00
GG bye bye